let's bring in katie pavlich news editor
of townhall.com and a fox news
contributor katie good to have you here
um
i want to start with this uh there was a
lot of attention given to the men on
horseback the border patrol and
horseback who were pushing people back
who were trying to cross
and there were suggestions that they
were using whips they say they don't
carry whips that they had the reins of
their horses that might have looked that
way and then jen saki was was asked
about this
on the plane on the way back from the
u.n meeting today and i want everyone to
listen to to what she said here and get
your response on the other side watch
this listen to this does the president
believe those border agents to be
punished in any way or is he just going
to wait for the investigation there's a
process in place for a reason obviously
we hope that investigation happens
quickly and it will determine as was
stated clearly in the secretary's
statement last night what disciplinary
action should be taken okay your
thoughts on that whole thing
well first martha i think this is just
another example of reporters writing and
talking about things that they have no
idea what they're talking about if you
know anything about western horse riding
you know that those are rains they are
not whips and yet you had democratic
operatives tweeting out these photos and
reporters jumped all over them and sent
it all the way up to the white house
yesterday with jen sake answering a
question uh yesterday and she said i
don't have all the context to the
situation but i'm not sure what the
context would be for this to happen well
first of all it didn't happen these
border patrol agents should be thanked
for defending the country for carrying
out their job to doing their duty to
protect the country as people come into
the country illegally and break the laws
and resist arrest and refuse to take
orders to not come over into the united
states without permission and without
legalization
and you had gensake repeating this
vicious lie and now they're saying that
they want an investigation and very
clearly these were not whips
these illegal immigrants were not being
whipped in the river they are being told
to step back from an international
border i think that this whole thing has
been desensitized in the sense that
people think this is an issue of police
brutality or maybe things are just
getting out of hand we're talking about
the sovereignty of a country here and
people seem to be offended that border
patrol agents were simply doing their
job and now the white house wants an
investigation into these patriotic
dutiful men who are protecting del rio
texas from an onslaught of illegal
immigration and then you have the state
department yesterday issuing a statement
saying well i've talked to the prime
minister of haiti and indicated that
it's very dangerous for
migrants illegal migrants to come into
the country well where is the statement
saying we're going to protect american
communities on the border from this kind
of onslaught of behavior and from
refugee camps that are being set up
inside of their communities which of
course leads to crime which leads to
health issues that we've seen people not
being tested for covid and again the
white house speaking out on an issue
which they claimed at the beginning they
actually didn't have full contacts on so
these agents have been completely
smeared and uh you know these border
communities are grateful that somebody
is stepping up to protect them from this
increased and never ending flow of
illegal immigration is stunning i think
you're right the people become
desensitized to it i always you know ask
myself how would you feel people started
rushing the turnstiles at customs at an
airport
in you know as you enter the united
states and just climbing over them and
coming into the country that's what's
happening at the southern border can you
imagine what it would be like if that
happened at one of our other ports of
entry um katie thank you very much we're
gonna leave it there hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now